madeleine blême aurait martin biron
bonsoir
allons-y avec ce panel politique est le
premier élément sur notre liste tout
haut haut bas c'est ce débat qui a eu
lieu hier du parti conservateur du
canada c'est la course à la direction
cinq des six candidats s'y trouvait au
chant center ottawa 90 minutes de
tension je dirais avant qu'on commence
sur le fond parlons de la forme
j'aimerais vous en tendant un premier
tour d'horizon là tu voyais et messieurs
charest et poilievre qui ne se sont pas
serré la main vous voyez comment tous
les autres se serrent la main sur ces
deux là les deux leaders selon les sons
que les les sondages quinté fait jusqu'à
présent petit tour d'horizon la tuque
est ce que vous avez pensé de la non la
teneur des échanges et cette tension
couper au couteau madeleine c'était
surprenant quand même avec si c'est rare
qu'on voit des débats en famille où on
est aussi agressif généralement on se
garde une petite gêne généralement on se
garde une petite gêne parce qu'on sait
que il y à un après course et qu'il faut
essayer de garder une certaine cohésion
dans le parti on sait qu'il ya des
lignes de fracture et les candidats ont
rien fait pierre poilievre jean charest
je dirais peut-être dans une moindre
mesure ont rien fait pour essayer de
garder ce parti-là soudé hier et
aujourd'hui liot des candidats qui en
ont parlé je pense par exemple à
monsieur atchison qui dit scott atchison
qui dit c'était embarrassant en fait ça
nuit au parti il ya parce que patrick
brown qui n'était pas là qui a dit ça à
était moi le gagnant de la soirée hier
en n'étant pas là il y avait des cris
j'étais mieux d'être ailleurs en train
de bâtir le parti soit c'est une bonne
excuse je vous dirai pas parce que on
pourrait aussi lui reprocher de ne pas
avoir participé à l'exercice mais
c'était un ton qui était
particulièrement acrimonieux et s'était
même surprenant à quel point ça d'été
martine elle c'est rare qu'on voit une
telle 1
dans des candidats du même parti et
quand on regarde de ce débat là ils
étaient cinq sur la scène on avait
vraiment l'impression qu'on avait que
deux au québec bah c'est ça ouvre un peu
leur idole sur certains candidats le
pierre poilievre il est moins connu au
québec
les textes qui ont été publiées les
analyses qui ont été les gens qui le
connaissent et que le suivent beaucoup
ottawa disait de lui qu'il était
particulièrement agressif et je pense
que c'est pas mal l'image qu'il a montré
ça confirme ça pour ce qui de jean
charest balle on le connaît plus et on
moi même je les couverts beaucoup quand
il était au parti libéral et je vous
raconte une anecdote 2012 jean charest
déclenché des élections on est en pleine
crise étudiante le taux d'insatisfaction
du gouvernement de monsieur charest est
en haut des 60% il a un vent de face
terrible pauline marois a le vent dans
le dos et il a fait une campagne en
enragé tout le long de cette campagne
électorale jusqu'à la dernière seconde
généralement la 9e que la veille du
scrutin et un souper du chef il ya un
nul et ça y est un événement partisan il
a fait campagne jusqu'à la dernière
seconde il ya presque gagné russe un
gouvernement minoritaire et c'est ce
jean charest l'a 10 ans plus tard que
j'ai vu hier sur la scène attendez vous
à une bataille de chaque seconde oui et
avant de poursuivre je pense qu'on ne
peut pas parler de ce débat sans en
entendre un petit extrait allons-y tout
de suite d'un premier échange jarret
poilievre
[Applaudissements]
mais ce pôle des
sports ali bamba k
c'est quelque chose quand même et ce
n'était que 57 secondes de ce débat de
90 minutes madeleine sur le fond sur le
fond des choses et madeleine qu'est ce
que vous retenez bien martin disait tout
à l'heure on aurait dit qu'ils n'étaient
que 2 c'est vrai il ya des semaines où
il essayait de s'en mêler un peu entre
autres sur la question du convoi de
camionneurs et elle reprochait à pierre
poilievre de ne pas avoir appuyé
suffisamment le convoi de camionneurs
donc vous voyez à quel point le spectre
de ce parti là et quand même assez large
pierre poilievre essaie de le tirer à
droite madame lewis essaie de le tirer
encore plus à droite alors que jean
charest essaie de le garder un peu plus
au centre mais au delà du fait qu'il y
avait des batailles particulièrement
entre pierre poilievre et jean charest
je ne suis pas certaine que ce soient
les seuls dans ce parti là premièrement
me patrick brown j'en parlais il ya un
instant n'était pas présent donc au
prochain des boys devrait être là et
leslie ouest avec étant la seule
représentante de la droite sociale du
métier elle est anti avortement elle
pourrait récolter des appuis quand même
substantielle la dernière fois lors de
la dernière course était environ 30 pour
cent des appuis qu'il avait récolté
c'est pas banal donc moi j'ai
l'impression que pierre poilievre a
trouvé en jean charest un bon pote shing
bague c'est le point de chic back
parfait laisse les noës ne peut pas
jouer ce rôle là parce que s'il ya
plusieurs tours dans cette course là il
va vouloir compter sur ses appuis à elle
donc c'est quand même une dynamique qui
est pas si simple à analyser surtout que
c'est une course qui se comptent par
point chaque comptait le même nombre de
points donc même si on est très fort
dans l'ouest ça veut pas dire qu'on est
très fort dans l'est donc j'ai
l'impression que ce sont deux meneurs
mais je pense quand même qu'il faut
faire attention avant de déclarer que
patrick brown et laisse les deux
nourrissons complètement écartée de la
course mais comme quoi cette course nous
réserve peut-être encore des surprises
il était question évidemment
d'avortement hier puisque quoi le moitié
ou à peu près de ce caucus conservateur
et contre semble-t-il la notion
d'avortement ou à peu près une trentaine
de pour faciliter un an plus tôt si la
tia pardon c'est le tien c'est vrai
c'est juste le tiers mais quand même
c'est significatif dans le contexte
canadien après tout parlant des
répercussions de ce qui s'est dit ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis et des
répercussions que ça chez nous on sait
que le québec avec vous martine par le
biais d'éric duhaime il était question
beaucoup cette semaine en fait elle sait
ce que c'est un électrochoc cette
nouvelle là au québec et monsieur
legault a donné le ton ainsi que la
plupart des partis d'opposition à 10,1 à
la cac il ya personne qui est pour
villon on est tous pro choix et il n'y a
pas de candidat pro choix il n'ya pas de
député pro choix j'accepte passa les
parties de poussan sont allés plus loin
en disant ne devrait pas accepter
un candidat qui était et qui est contre
l'avortement et l'idée c'était
effectivement
d'isoler éric duhaime qui a un candidat
qui est ouvertement contre l'avortement
et c'est un médecin qui se présente dans
la circonscription de notre dame de
grâce alors sa force et le chef
conservateur à faire une sortie il s'est
défendu en disant ben écoutez et tout le
monde a droit à ses convictions - comme
chef du parti conservateur je n'ai aucun
appétit pour qu'on revoie cet enjeu là
et mais ça demeure une carte ça va
devenir une c'est une tuile pour
monsieur duhaime parce que les la
population au québec et les favorables à
l'avortement
il ya un accès ce sont les provinces qui
sont responsables de donner l'accès à
l'avortement et au québec il ya un accès
relativement bon mais aussi que c'est
fragile on voit que d'autres provinces
ne donne pas le même accès alors ça ça
demeure
une embûche pour monsieur faible où est
cette variation dans les accises s'est
fait en sorte que monsieur trudeau sera
peut-être tenté de tirer sur certaines
ficelles madeleine et en plus bayel
l'occasion de pouvoir torpiller les
adversaires conservateurs n'ont eu à
propos des actions de laxey alexis
d'abord sa place et justin trudeau quand
même un peu sur la sellette cette
semaine parce que c'était une promesse
électorale du parti libéral de se servir
de la loi canadienne sur la santé pour
améliorer l'accès à l'avortement au pays
c'était donc lors des dernières
élections aient lieu rien qui a été fait
depuis à ce chapitre là donc
l'opposition néo-démocrate dix bombes et
c'est bien beau de parler d'avortement
des valeurs maintenant fait en sorte que
l'accès soit améliorée au pays parce que
le droit il existe c'est du côté de
l'accès qu'un problème donc sa place est
un petit peu justin trudeau dans une
position vulnérable
il a évoqué la possibilité de légiférer
ça aussi ça a suscité certaines craintes
entre autres du bloc québécois 10 ans
mieux vaut ne pas nécessairement ouvrir
cette boîte de pandore parce que si on
légifère il ya une possibilité de pente
savonneuse si on légifère s'il ya une
loi c'est plus facile après de l'amendé
de la changer et ça pourrait entraîner
des restrictions à l'avortement au pays
donc ça c'est pour la semaine un petit
peu plus compliqué je dirais pour justin
trudeau mais c'est vrai que
systématiquement lorsqu'il est question
d'avortement il veut peser sur ce bouton
là mais parce qu'il sait que les
conservateurs sont vulnérables on le
disait tout à l'heure la à peu près le
tiers du caucus et contre l'avortement
c'est un caucus qui est divisé sur cette
question là alors que la population
canadienne pas seulement québécoise mais
la population canadienne est
majoritairement favorables à
l'avortement
probablement le marché que c'est encore
plus fort au québec j'ai pas les
statistiques entre le québec et le
canada mais au pays en général la
population canadienne est généralement
pour le fait qu'on conserve ce droit des
femmes de choisir c'est ce qui se dégage
à quelques quelques quand même une
petite minute pour parler martin avec
vous de ce 10e départ annoncé au sein du
parti libéral du québec pour leur bétail
au terme de son premier mandat seulement
web assez différent des autres des neuf
autres parce que justement
elle est là depuis seulement un mandat
et elle s'est démarquée pendant la
pandémie le quartier de montreynaud
c'est dans sa circonscription même le
ministre de la santé christian dubé
avait salué son travail sur le terrain
c'est un peu étonnant une visiblement
est quelque chose qui marchait pas avec
dominique anglade quand elle a commencé
elle avait des beaux dossiers comme par
exemple les relations internationales
qui est dans ses cordes ou encore la
lutte contre la pauvreté dans ses cordes
également mais depuis septembre elle est
en charge de l'agriculture honnêtement
on n'est pas loin de la tablette avec
seul
et vous beaucoup de mots tête en
perspective pour madame anglade merci
beaucoup madeleine et martin ont
conservé le deuxième débat des candidats
à la course à la direction du pcc et le
congrès de l'union des municipalités du
québec merci beaucoup mais dame est
bonne cette semaine au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit